what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are covering night terrors now this
story basically opens up with Batman
being choked to death
but there is something to explain here
about night terrors the idea behind this
story is that the guy here who's choking
Batman this is a new villain being
introduced to us known as insomnia this
guy has the ability to alter reality in
such a way to where he can take at least
on some level people's nightmares and
bring them into the real world now he is
hunting for an artifact that will allow
him to do that on seemingly a universal
scale and make it more powerful than
anything we've ever seen before and
we'll talk about what that artifact is
here in a little bit but this version of
Batman that you see is Batman but it's
not Batman one of the things that
insomnia had done when he entered into
the world is he initiated something
called The Nightmare wave basically
anybody who was already asleep at that
point in time which sort of thrust into
their worst nightmares and is just
reliving them over and over again so for
those of you guys who are familiar with
Marvel Comics this guy's basically just
nightmare from Marvel that's really all
he is but the thing about this is that
Batman despite the fact that he's being
choked by insomnia is actually asleep
what's really happening here is he's
currently possessed by a guy named
Boston Brand also known as dead man now
dead man is basically a kind of Specter
that floats around the world he inhabits
the bodies of people sometimes out of
curiosity just to see what their lives
are like other times because he has to
like communicate a message to all the
superheroes who are out there one of the
things that had taken place leading up
to this in a story called night terrors
First Blood was basically when insomnia
made his move Boston bran possessed
Batman tried to warn Batman Superman and
Wonder Woman but it was simply just too
late and they were ultimately trapped in
their own mental state and that was
basically it and so what Boston Brand
does is he actually leaves the body of
Batman and then enters into the body of
insomnia because from his perspective he
wants to know what this guy's about that
when he asks him like what's your whole
Spiel the response of insomnia is I'm
the literal God of nightmares now here's
what's so cool about this that what
happens is once Boston and brand enters
into the body and really the mind of
insomnia he starts looking through
everything and he realizes this guy's
hunting for something called The
Nightmare Stone now what's the nightmare
Stone the nightmare stone is actually a
modified version of What's called the
dreamstone what's the dreamstone so in
DC Comics The Dream stone is an artifact
that was created by what you and I would
call a cosmic entity known as dream of
the Endless and that anybody who
possesses the dream Stone if they have
the wherewithal to do it can channel the
dreams of everybody in the world who's
sleeping and then turn those dreams into
physical manifestations essentially
altering reality now what had actually
happened here is that somewhere along
the line the dreamstone was taken by Dr
Destiny and then eventually a guy named
John D and it was perverted and twisted
and turned into a nightmare Stone so in
effect it does the exact same thing the
dreamstone does the difference is that
it feeds on nightmares instead of dreams
and so that's exactly exactly what an
insomnia is hunting for if he attains
this he'd basically be able to keep the
World In Perpetual sleep and presumably
even be able to take over the entirety
of the universe because virtually every
organism in existence has to sleep at
some point now the other thing that
Boston Brand realizes in scanning this
guy's mind is he ends up coming across
Arkham Tower and that's when he realizes
this God of nightmares is not a god at
all he's just a guy and in fact
somewhere along the line this guy was
exposed to the Lazarus Reign now in DC
Comics there was a story that took place
relatively recently called Lazarus
planet and that in DC Comics you have
something called The Lazarus Pit which
is basically a giant liquid whereby if
you're severely injured and sometimes
even dead you can be put inside that
Lazarus Pit and you'll come back you'll
experience temporary insanity but
eventually you'll regain your composure
during the events of Lazarus Planet what
had happened is that the Lazarus resin
or the Lazarus Pit whatever you want to
call it within a volcano that substance
had basically been exposed to the helmet
of Dr Fate and when that happened it
imbued the rain with magical properties
why does that matter because DC
basically used it as a way to bring back
superheroes who were dead so when a
person is exposed to the Lazarus resin
they're not truly alive but they're not
truly dead they're not quite a zombie
they're just kind of somewhere in
between but for some people it gave them
powers in this instance it gave this guy
the ability to at least take people's
Nightmares on some level and manifest
them in the physical world but once he
gets the nightmare Stone assuming that
he actually does he would become almost
Godly in terms of power now one of the
other things that Boston Brand realizes
is that this guy is basically taking his
happy memories and like keeping them
hidden away we don't really know why but
basically he's shutting off that part of
himself that is loving caring and
compassionate now eventually Boston
Brand is expelled out of the body of
insomnia now this is not really uncommon
in the sense that if a person has enough
fortitude or they have enough mental
control they can force Boston Brand out
of their own body but Boston bran
realizes this guy's just a dude and
there's no real reason to concern
himself with this dude in particular
like to hang around here and just kind
of see what happens and so he basically
ends up fleeing the entire building now
one of the things that insomnia hits at
is that when he's in this place which is
to say when he's in the real world the
reality is that his power begins to kind
of dwindle so he's very similar to
Mephisto from Marvel Comics right the
longer Mephisto is away from his own
realm the weaker he becomes it's the
same thing here so this guy ends up
having to teleport back to the nightmare
realm but basically brings out a few of
his henchmen to try to track down Boston
Brand in the body of Batman in order to
capture him and the reason for this is
because Boston Brand comes to the
realization that even if he doesn't
necessarily know where the nightmare
stone is and essentially no one knows
where it is he does believe he knows of
a guy who has long since been dead that
may very well know where the stone is
actually located so jumping out of a
building and basically using like these
weird Wild looking Twisted Vines where
the whole earth is basically being
mutated and then getting down to the
Batmobile and taking off this guy heads
to a graveyard and one of the coolest
things about this is what this guy's
actually doing because let me understand
not everyone in the world is asleep
right people don't all go to sleep in
the world at the same time so you do
have characters like Red Tornado who
doesn't really sleep because he's
basically a robot you've got zatana
who's just a really powerful magic
wheeler you've got people out there who
are trying to understand who this
insomnia guy is and trying to find some
way to defeat him but once Boston bran
gets to this graveyard what he says is
this guy here has long since been dead
and that while the Lazarus Reign had
basically been wiped away from pretty
much the entirety of the earth Batman
ever the guy who's preparing for
everything had kept some of the vials
within the bat cave and so what Boston
bran did is he grabbed the vials took
him to the graveyard and then poured
them all over this grave after partially
digging it up and what it does is it
brings this guy kind of back from the
dead oh only for us to find out it's
Wesley Dodds it's the Sandman now why
does that matter because Sandman has a
very close history with dream of the
Endless so much so that in the early
days of his publication history the two
of them had met and because of his
encounter with dream he actually had
these kind of prophetic Visions for
those of you guys who ever read kingdom
come if you were wondering how it was
that like Sandman would have these
visions of like war in the future and
all that kind of stuff right the
superhero Civil War and DC Comics that
was because of his encounter with the
endless right that's the power that he
has but more so than that because Wesley
Dodds and because dream were so closely
knit right so close to each other if
anyone in the world would know where the
nightmare stone is because it's
basically a mutated version of the
dreamstone it would be Wesley so this is
cool it's exciting not the most exciting
thing ever the tie-ins are definitely a
little more interesting than the main
story but I am excited to see where it
goes so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end and I will
catch you all later
peace